notre dossier est consacré ce soir au
gris de toul c'est la seule et unique
production vinicole de la lorraine une
production très local dont la notoriété
dépasse à peine les frontières de l'est
de la france
bref un vin intimiste qui n'a pas la
prétention des grands crus mais qui
mérite le détour d'autant que derrière
le great thou lilly a toute une région à
découvrir celle des côtes de toul où
l'on prépare consciencieusement les
vendanges du mois d'octobre prochain
le reportage de pascal hennuy
la vigne en lorraine est une très
ancienne tradition on retrouve sa trace
à l'époque des gaulois
les robes a ensuite n'ont fait
qu'intensifier cette culture maintenant
le seul bastion du vignoble le rincer le
toulois
une soixantaine de vignerons travaillent
encore la vigne mais 15 seulement en
vivent
les autres sont des doubles actif pour
la plupart salariés il serait parti dans
quelques charmants villages dans les
côtes de toul
au total neuf d'entre eux sont
détenteurs de l'appellation vdqs vins
gris des côtes de toul les plus célèbres
de ces villages relais lui c'est mon
l'ignoble ligne le travail est dur et
les exploitations plutôt petit ne
permettent pas une mécanisation à
outrance
ici et là on voit bien quelques engins
mais beaucoup travaillé à la main la
vigne est pour une tradition familiale
et les racines sont bien entrées dans
ces coteaux en ce moment c'est le
rognage on coupe le rejet qui gêne la
vigne
j'ai vécu jusque 22 25
et puis après ça va vite ça nourrit
circulaire la famille des freezes pas
payé je suis souvent les choisit cool
mais pour garder qu à me contacter je
suis en crise donc on avait planté pour
éviter que la tradition ne disparaisse
un groupe d'enseignants du tube doit
réaménager une maison de vigneron a eu
c'est ce n'est pas un musée mais plutôt
un lieu éducatif réservé aux enfants des
écoles de la ville dans le cadre des
projets d'éducation ils ont appelé à
connaître le vignoble le rhin madame
bouchaud la propriétaire de cette maison
a toujours vécu ici
elle exploitait bien sûr la vie n'y
avait que son mari mais vivait la
polyculture à l'époque les journées de
travail était bien remplie
aujourd'hui on partait du matin un homme
délicat scott sentant casser la cour
alors vers 9h10 heure en avion avait des
ouvriers dans des casques pour l'heureux
de gamme angers puis alors après en
vendent à midi on les nourrit sa midi
puis il ya toujours eu une âme il en a
toujours été 2 aujourd'hui montrent ici
alors c'est comme ça bien peu compliqué
mais nous y retourner parfois dans les
villes on veut j'y suis tout le temps ça
qu'on voit qui est arrivé il ya des
enfants
il y en a deux qui font les vices et
deux frères alors sais pas qui tu ailles
quoi typhi la feuille qui valent gay
jusque tard j'aimerais y aller si je
peux on peut vous demander votre âge
1 quel âge vous avez 24 20 heures jeudi
que faire lorsque des fuites est menacée
se regrouper quelques producteurs ont
donc créé ingénieux et gère un centre de
promotion des produits du toulois à
brûler un bon moyen pour se faire
connaître
voici dans la carte de monsieur masson à
bobigny depuis 786 de père en fils on
cultive la vigne mais maintenant il n'y
a plus de relève
ben je sais pas ce qui se passera c'est
quand même les enfants un fils cimaises
mais à une salariée
il vient comme dans l'élite mais a raté
de fans profession bancaire
c'est au début quand il est parti oui
mais après nous quand on voit ce qui se
passe je pense que c'est la bonne
formule des salariés maintenant nous
sommes de nouveau à brûler c'est une
période creuse pour les vignerons un peu
de rognage bien sûr mais en attendant
les vendanges milieu octobre en lorraine
on met du vin en bouteille et on les
prépare
c'est un travail lent fastidieux
artisanale fernand poirson exploite seul
avec sa femme ses trois hectares et demi
de vigne il aime la vie mais son produit
mais il sait que cela va être difficile
plus tard même très difficile
oui mes parents étaient viticulteurs mes
grands parents aussi du côté de ma mère
est du côté de mon père enfin jusqu'à
mon père on était un ailier
alors voyez c'est probablement par
atavisme plus que je suis resté
viticulteurs et après vous qu'est ce qui
va se passer après moi ce sera
certainement un problème alors
pessimistes les vignerons du toulois
non quand même pas d'autant plus que
cette année le soleil daigne encore se
montrer la récolte sera très abondante
et le gris ne manquera pas dans les
cuves